there's a new report that Donald Trump
has abandoned his goal of forcing regime
change in Venezuela essentially because
it's difficult and complicated and he no
longer has the patience for it and he's
effectively gotten bored and moved on to
other things which sounds exactly like
what Donald Trump would do when
something gets difficult as many of you
know whether you agree with me or you
disagree with me my position on
Venezuela has been clear for years the
Chavez Maduro regimes have been
absolutely disastrous for Venezuela
I want Maduro out for the benefit of the
Venezuelan people but the United States
cannot have anything to do with it the
United States cannot be the entity that
forces Maduro out the United States
cannot be the entity that chooses
Nicolas Maduro replacement they can't be
forced in or selected by the United
States our involvement in Latin America
over the last 50 plus years has been
nothing short of catastrophic we backed
a coup in Honduras in 2009 our
involvement in Argentina and Chile with
the repressive regimes of the 1970s
through which by the way my parents live
lived through through which my parents
live I was born in Argentina in 1984
just a few years after the military
dictatorship fell disastrous American
involvement there in the 1980s backing
anti-communist contra forces in
Nicaragua while backing the right-wing
Salvadoran government disastrous
involvement in Latin America and then
more generally I mean our entire role
and involvement with Cuba and the
embargo dating back for decades it's a
very long list we do not want the United
States involved in Latin America and for
a while it really seemed like getting
involved in Venezuela was a top priority
for Donald Trump but and this is good
news it seems that Donald Trump has
become frustrated and sort of impatient
with what's going on in Venezuela and
according to insiders he's lost interest
and basically moved on to a new toy and
that new toy might be Iran it might be
starting to do a bunch of rallies for
the 2020 reelection campaign that is now
getting going in in in earnest and in
full force this is good okay this is
another reminder that issues
which could really influence huge
numbers of people's lives are dependent
on whether Donald Trump is board which
is horribly scary and disturbing and
embarrassing for the United States on
the national stage but this is a good
thing and there's a very good new report
in The Washington Post which says that
pushing regime change in Venezuela
really was looking attractive to trump
during the winter Trump wanted a win he
kind of needed a win he had failed
endlessly with China and the trade
policy and the bogus destructive tariffs
the North Korea negotiations
negotiations at number two with Kim
jong-un failed and he was really looking
for a win with Venezuela and then things
sort of got stuck Maduro didn't leave
Venezuela when it seemed maybe he would
the Trump administration had no clear
path to his removal reports from inside
the White House are now that Donald
Trump simply lost patience and he lost
interest sort of like a little kid who
fails three times to beat a level in a
video game and decides to go play with
his Legos and there are counter points
to these reports from some who say well
Trump hasn't a van abandoned Venezuela
he's going to keep working on it it's
just there's kind of a break right now
this is basically a case of who knew
being president could be so hard but
it's a very good thing it is terrible
that our president just gets bored with
difficult things and abandons them this
is not a good trait for a president but
in this particular case it's good that
Donald Trump got bored and frustrated
with regime change in Venezuela because
we want the United States staying as far
from regime change in Venezuela as
possible now it could be argued that the
Obamacare repeal ultimately didn't
happen for similar reasons that Donald
Trump got frustrated and bored he wanted
to do a repeal he campaigned on a repeal
Republicans put together multiple
ludicrous bills that would have been
terrible for tens of millions of
Americans they didn't pass ultimately
even Republicans couldn't agree on the
right way to repeal Obamacare and then
Trump ended up just removing the
individual mandate for Obamacare in his
tax
plan and effectively has moved on it
seems that something similar has
happened in Venezuela and we just have
to come to terms with the reality that
American policy both domestic and
international is ultimately coming down
to whether staff can keep Donald Trump
interested with pictures and charts and
compliments about how great he would
look if he was able to get something
done we've truly never seen anything
like this before
we've seen crooked presidents before
we've seen presidents with all of the
wrong ideas reactionaries of neoliberal
war hawks we've seen all of that stuff
before we've even seen ignorant in
presidents before remember george w bush
but we've never seen anything like this
in the sense that the degree to which
Donald Trump is bored with something or
frustrated with the fact that diplomacy
is a real thing things don't just happen
at the snap of a fingers maybe he's used
to happening in the Trump Organization
we've never had that boredom and
frustration so directly determined what
the legislative priorities are and the
geopolitical priorities are of an entire
administration it's truly something else
make sure you're following the David
Pakman show on Instagram where we are
asking you questions about what Donald
Trump should and shouldn't be focusing
on at David Pakman show is the David
Pakman show Instagram account and while
you're there follow me on Instagram as
well
at David Pakman if you love learning new
things you probably want to check this
out the David Pakman show today is
sponsored by Skillshare and we're giving
you two entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting
I'm still not good but I am learning and
you can access the entire library of fun
easy-to-use online courses for free for
two months by using the link underneath
this video two months of learning
something that's totally new to you
something you want to get better at
something you already love or you can
get ahead in your career by learning new
skills that will help you at your job
I've gotten a ton out of it Pat has
taken some courses that he's found
really valuable and I think you'll love
it to get started for free by clicking
the link under this video